découvrir ou redécouvrir les richesses
naturelles de sa région et savoir en
prendre soin c'était l'objectif de la
seconde édition de la fête de la nature
elle s'est tenue samedi 11 juin à pau
d'arte une manifestation initiée depuis
2015 par les jeunes de la ville c'est
les jeunes du conseil municipal qui ont
décidé en fait de mettre en place cette
fête de la nature ça fait longtemps
qu'ils en parlent ils n'avaient vraiment
à coeur de faire de mettre en place un
vrai projet en sur l'environnement
bourse aux plantes ateliers et
animations
une douzaine de stands étaient proposés
les visiteurs ont pu notamment s'initier
à la réalisation d'une greffe ou encore
donner une deuxième vie à des objets
inutilisés ou a rejeté dans la nature
on essaye un petit peu de mettre en
garde les personnes effectivement de
faire attention et de montrer par
diverses divers stands qui sont ici
présents que voilà il faut y faire
attention et on a tous la possibilité à
notre niveau de faire quelque chose
après d'avoir diffusé en 2015
le film home cette année et son
réalisateur yann arthus bertrand qui a
été invité il est venu tenir une
conférence sur le thème de la nature et
du développement durable quand on parle
environnement pense souvent à ces films
qui sont vraiment avant gardiste parce
que c'est un vraiment un des premiers à
avoir fait à grande échelle au niveau de
la planète voilà des mises en garde très
important près de 500 personnes sont
venues fêter la nature une journée
clôturée par une soirée de concerts
face à ces succès une troisième édition
est déjà envisagée